في ذروه المعارك المحتدمه في ضخمه
الاوكرانيه خطر اساسي يهدد التقدم الروسي
وهو خلافات الصف الواحد بين مجموعه فاقنر
التي تقاتل في المدينه والكرملين
قد تكون فاجنر فداء التالي لموسكو هذا ما
ذهب اليه معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي الذي
يرى ان الدفاع الروسيه تعطي الاولويه
حاليا للقضاء على قوات فاجنر في ضخمه بعد
الهجوم الحاد من قبل بريجوجين على وزير
الدفاع سيرجي شويغو ورئيس الاركان العامه
هناك مواجهه مباشره لا تقل عن كونها
محاوله لتدمير فاغنر وترقى الى خيانه
للوطن في حين تقاتل فاجنر من اجل باخموت
وتتكبد خسائر بشريه بالمئات كل يوم
الشقاق
في حد وصل لدرجه قطع وزاره الدفاع الذخيره
عن فاجنر بعد ان استنفذت كامل ذخيلتها في
المعارك وطلبت موسكو بالامدادات الغريب ان
الدفاع الروسيه قطعت طرق التواصل مع فاجنر
رغم ان الاخيره تحققت تقدما لافتا شرقيه
اوكرانيا وضمنت لموسكو السيطره على المزيد
من الاراضي
[موسيقى]
بعض المحللين يرون ان موسكو تتارجح بين
رغبتين الاولى هي انتزاع بخموت كنصر
استراتيجي يمهد الطريق نحو غربي اوكرانيا
والثانيه هي التغلب على مخاوف بوتين من
طموحات التوسعيه ومؤخرا كانت تقارير غربيه
تنبات بطموح بريروجين لتحويل فاجنر الى
منظومه عسكريه موازيه تحمل طابعا
ايديولوجيا ويكون لها دورها المنفصل عن
الكرملين في اوكرانيا الى عمر العربيه